لعنه التويتر تلحقوا ثروت الى بيانات
ميزانيه الملياردير الامريكي تظهر انها
غارقه بالخسائر وفق ما كشفه تقرير لموقع
اكسيوس الامريكي الذي احصى خسائر كبيره
للملياردير المثير للجدل خلال عام 2022
تظهر انه كان عامل خساره بامتياز الموقع
اشار الى ان الامر بالغ الاهميه نظرا الى
ان ماسك يعد ايقونه النجاح التكنولوجي في
العالم وبات اغنى رجل على الكوكب بثروه
تقدر وتقترب من 200 مليار دولار لكن
صفقاته الماليه هذا العام وعلى راسها شراء
تويتر قبل لات- من مدخيل ماسك والحقت
الاضرار براس ماله رغم ان ثروه ماسك تعد
بمئات المليارات الى ان المشكله الاساسيه
فيها تكمن في ان نسبه كبيره منها مرتبطه
مباشره باسهم شركه تسلا للسيارات
الكهربائيه والتي تراجعت بنسبه تصل الى
بالمئه في هذا العام
[موسيقى]